2019 год, город Нюренберг. Я сижу,
завтракаю с молодым миллиардером. Это
мой друг.
Он смотрит на меня и говорит: "Володь, я
тебе хочу сделать подарок". Ну а какой
подарок ожидать от миллиардера? Там
думаю, может машину подарит, там всякое
жем там, да. Там
на самом деле он подарил больше. Он
говорит: "Я тебе хочу подарить тренинг,
в котором обучает масонов, там польеров
и разных других ребят, как сделать так,
чтобы желания исполнялись". Ну и на тот
момент я, конечно же, уже читал
трансерфинг. Я пересмотрел, не знаю, там
раз 100 фильм Секрет, особенно когда он
появился. То есть я его чуть ли не
каждый день смотрел. Ну потому что вот
эта тема наш будоражит. Каждый же хочет
получить ключик, который будет исполнять
желание его жизни. Ну прикинь, тебе дают
ключи, говорят: "Любая дверь в твоей
жизни открыта. Хочешь денег, пожалуйста,
отношения, пожалуйста, здоровье, да, да,
всё возможно". И вроде бы я это всё
читал, изучал и вроде бы даже где-то
работает. Одно срабатывает, другое не
срабатывает.
жизнь меняется, но не так сильно и не
так быстро, как хотелось бы. А тут раз
такой подгон,
и он ещё говорит: "Вот всё то, что там
говорится, я применил, это реально
работает". Я говорю: "Ну давай".
Посмотрел, изучил. Я был приятно удивлён
тому, о чём там говорилось. Есть вещи,
которые не говорились там в других
источниках, про которые я сейчас
говорил. Но в итоге, что я хочу сказать?
Это знаешь, вот когда пообедаешь плотно,
вроде поел, вроде бы полный, а вот
чего-то не хватает, да? Вот не хватает
вот какой-нибудь конфетки, что-нибудь
такое вот сладенькое. Вот так раз и
понимаешь, всё шлифанул, всё прямо вот
вот прям всё склеилось теперь. И как
будто вот тоже вроде бы всё меняется,
вроде бы всё хорошо, но как будто
чего-то не хватает. И слава богу, я уже
с 2014 года изучал Веды. И так как ты,
изучая Веды, а там ответы по сути на все
вопросы, ты можешь как бы углубляясь в
какую-то конкретную тему, искать это в
Ведах. И, соответственно, изучая эту
тему, углубляясь в неё, благодаря Ведам,
я получил ключи, которых, может быть, не
хватало тогда. В этом видео я хочу
поделиться с тобой двенадцатью
осознаниями, которые могут очень сильно
изменить твою жизнь. пожалуйста, сохрани
это видео и периодически его
пересматривай, дабы смотреть на каком
этапе, где где где из вот этих
двенадцати пунктов может быть где-то ты
пробуксовываешь или, может быть, что-то
ты не допонял. В любом случае, сохраняй
и пересматривай. Первое, что нужно
понять, когда мы думаем о проблемах, мы
опираемся на прошлый опыт, который
записан у нас в подсознании. Простыми
словами, всё, что мы проживали
позитивное и негативное в прошлом, это
оставило отпечатки в нашем подсознании.
Они называются самскары. Вот этот
негативный прошлый опыт, он всегда
связан с какими-то людьми. И вот теперь,
если ты думаешь о какой-то проблеме, то
эта проблема выходит наружу за счёт
какого-то прошлого опыта в твоём
отпечатке, в твоём подсознании. Оно
выводится наружу. И научно доказано,
что та проблема, которую ты проживаешь в
уме,
наш мозг воспринимает её так же реально,
как если бы ты её проживал в реальности.
Второе, что необходимо понять, тот
негативный опыт, который мы проживали в
прошлом.
Если он до сих пор остался в нашем
подсознании как нерешённая проблема, он
до сих пор влияет на всю нашу жизнь.
Другими словами, как это влияет на
здоровье, на жизнь в полном, да, и как
это связано с вот этой темой исполнения
желаний. Смотри,
когда мы проживаем какую-то негативную
ситуацию, спектр каких-то эмоций,
предательства, измен, вот что-то
негативное, да, насилие какое-то, в
подсознании остаётся очень глубокий
отпечаток. И в своё время доктор Хамер -
это очень интересный дядечка, он же
оставил тело,
научно его не признавали, медицина его
топила, но при этом его направление
новой германской медицина сейчас очень
пользуется популярностью, спросом, да,
психосоматика.
И он объяснил, что когда мы испытываем
какую-то негативную ситуацию, то у нас в
мозгу остаётся отпечаток. Да, он его
назвал очаг хамра.
И вот этот очаг Хаммера, он остаётся в
той части мозга, который отвечает за
конкретный орган. Другими словами,
человек прожил какую-то негативную
ситуацию
в детстве
вопрос не решился, она осталась там
закупоренная, остал сильный отпечаток.
Вот этот отпечаток из подсознания
продавливает отпечаток в мозгу. Ну,
образно сказано, мозг начинает влиять на
какой-то орган, то есть бить по нему,
да, и так возникает болезнь. И он
говорит, что большинство болезней,
которые есть у человека - это вот эти
как раз-таки отпечатки, то есть
психологически нерешённые проблемы,
которые у нас есть, которые в итоге до
сих пор влияют на наше здоровье. И
другим, другими словами, он доказал, что
когда мы распутываем вот эту негативную
ситуацию в прошлом, да, то орган
начинает восстанавливаться. Но я здесь
хочу донести немножко другую мысль.
Каждый раз, когда ты думаешь снова и
снова о какой-то проблеме, каждый раз,
когда ты снова и снова гуляешь в своих
негативных мыслях, каждый раз, когда ты
чем-то неудовлетворён, дыр-дыр-др-др, у
тебя вот здесь крутится,
ты снова и снова отпечатаешь подсознание
негатив. То есть ты бьёшь в тот
отпечаток,
который связан с этим негативом из
прошлого. Да, посмотри первый пример,
который я проговаривал про мысль, да,
что проблема, откуда она возникает. Вот.
И снова и снова, думая об этом, ты тем
самым в первую очередь бьёшь по своему
здоровью. Но самое интересное, что это
будет также влиять и на твои отношения,
это будет также влиять и на твою
финансовую сферу, это также будет влиять
э на то, насколько то, чего ты желаешь,
ты будешь это получать, или, наоборот,
то, чего ты не желаешь, ты будешь это
получать. И вот это важно понять.
Второе, да? Третье. Наша мысль, которая
крутится у нас в голове, рождает у нас
внутреннее состояние. То есть мы себя
чувствуем определённым образом. Когда мы
думаем о негативном. Состояние у нас не
позитивное, да? У нас может быть лёгкое
раздражение, может быть наоборот больше
раздражения
или наоборот, когда у тебя какая-то раз
приятная мысль те, а внутри тоже стало
хорошо. То есть это понятно. Но теперь
смотри, то состояние, в котором мы
находимся, другими словами, мысль родила
состояние. И то состояние, в котором мы
теперь совершаем действие любое, мы
будем получать результат. И вот этот
результат, первое, он сразу будет
приходить в том состоянии, в котором мы
это проживаем. И второе, он будет
закладывать семена будущее, которые
также дадут результат именно с этим же
состоянием. Объясняю прямо сейчас, если
ты кому-то тебе в ответ так же, ну,
соответственно, скорее всего будет
негативно идти, да, по отношению к тебе.
Даже если человек тебе ничего не скажет,
он тебя будет просто без слов
ненавидеть. А это также будет бить по
твоему тонкому полю, поверью, родной.
Это очень важно понимать. И второе,
ладно, в моменте прямо сейчас, создавая
или действуя в негативном состоянии, ты
получаешь негативную обратку, потому что
от тебя идёт агрессия, ты агрессивно
настроен, да? Второе, семена, которые ты
сейчас сеешь, действия, которые
совершаешь, да, это семена, которые
приведут ещё в будущем к тому, чтобы ты
прожил это же состояние. Ну, только
агрессия уже вернулась в твою сторону.
Если ты кого-то обидел, то обязательно
придёт тот, кто обидит тебя. Если ты
кого-то предал, то обязательно придёт
тот, кто предаст тебя. Ну то есть то,
что мы наружу выкидываем, а из-за чего
мы выкидываем? Мысль, состояние,
действие из этого состояния, результат.
Поэтому всё, что негативное ты делаешь
другому человеку, оно вернётся
обязательно в твою жизнь. Вот это важно
понимать, родной. Либо это нужно
отключать, если ты не хочешь, чтобы это
вернулось в твою жизнь. Это тоже
возможно, но об этом дальше. Четвёртое.
Негативная мысль, которая возникает у
нас в голове, она сужает пространство
выбора человека, и она влияет на
энергетику человека. Давай теперь с этим
разберёмся. Это очень важно. Что значит
сужает пространство выбора? Когда ты в
негативе, у тебя выбор сужается. И
теперь вроде бы из широкого выбора всего
того, что можно иметь в жизни, ты будешь
концентрироваться именно на том, что
будет подтверждать твоё состояние. Так
как ты в негативе, ты будешь совершать
из этого негатива именно действия,
которые будут негативно также
возвращаться в твою жизнь. Ну то есть ты
их будешь воспринимать негативно.
Другими словами, это называется тамос.
Тамас или раджас - это две энергии, две
вибрации, которые сужают состояние
человека. Вот небольшой пример, который
случился сегодня ночью. Просыпаясь под
поддеяльником, и мне холодно. Думаю,
где-то у меня здесь лежит одеяло. Да,
скорее всего, я его вытащил, жена там
положила, я его возьму сейчас и укроюсь
сверху. И сон, такой раз открывает там,
а там одеяло, но оно слишком тёплое, то
есть я его не хочу. И я такой думаю: "О,
а что тогда?" Да. А это тамас. Тамас -
это когда ты уставший, сонный, когда ты
в негативе находишься. Это тамос, да?
Это состояние же определённое.
И такой ум: "В, халат лежит, давай
укройсь халатом". Хорошо. Беру халат и
укрываюсь халатом.
И мне становится хорошо. Но [фыркает]
при этом всём, если бы я был первое в
чистом состоянии, не уставший, я бы
нашёл конкретно то, чего я хочу, а
недовольствовался бы просто халатом и
старался бы в него поместиться. Второе
состояние, в котором я был, уставший,
да, тамос. Энергетика просажена,
соответственно, я не хочу совершать
много действий, мне быстрее лечь и
поспать. И также, когда негативные мысли
у нас, первое - это сужает наш выбор.
Выбор в негатив. То есть мы будем
действовать из негатива и получать
негатив. И вторую у нас просаживается
очень сильная энергетика. Поэтому люди,
которые постоянно или часто находятся в
неудовлетворении, в раздражении, у них
просто нет энергии.
>> Как ты думаешь в таком состоянии, когда
ты постоянно зафиксирован на негатив?
Как ты будешь общаться со своим
партнёром? Как ты будешь общаться со
своими детьми? Как ты будешь общаться со
своими любимыми? Ну скажи мне, позитивно
нет. жёстко предъявлять,
проявлять неудовлетворение, раздражение,
докапываться,
и в итоге отношения рушится. А как это
будет влиять на твою финансовую сферу,
если ты живёшь вот в этом туннеле
негативного состояния и у тебя часто
крутятся вот эти мысли: страх,
неудовлетворение, обида, чувство вины?
Приведёт ли это к хорошему заработку, к
финансам, к развитию, к тому, что перед
тобой открыт весь мир? Да, всё, возьми,
что хочешь. Нет, в этом состоянии ты
будешь брать минимум, и тот будет не
позитивный. И энергетики для того, чтобы
что-то ещё взять другое, что-то сделать,
тоже не будет. Пятое. Для того, чтобы
раскрыть весь свой потенциал, сыграть в
этой жизни по максимуму,
тебе нужна частота. На санскрите
эта вибрация энергии называется сатва.
То есть всё, что то, что ты смотришь,
всё то, что ты кушаешь, слушаешь,
всё, с чем мы соприкасаемся через органы
чувств, влияет как и на наше физическое
тело, так и влияет на наше тонкое тело.
И так, как мы сейчас разбираем вот эту
тему ментальности, ум, состояние,
отпечатки, проблемы, да, и исходя из
этого мы действуем, то важно понимать
то, что мы едим, то, что мы смотрим, с
кем мы разговариваем, на какие темы
разговариваем, какими словами мы
пользуемся. теримся мы или нет. Всё это
влияет не только на нашу физику, но и
влияет на наше тонкое тело, на нашу
психику, а именно на состояние. К
примеру, а лук, да, с точки зрения
физиологии, с точки зрения там
макро-микроэлементов для тела это очень
позитивный продукт, там много витаминов,
всё такое. Но если взять психику, то он
будет поднимать в подсознании
ряд отпечатков, которые связаны с
проблемами, которые связаны с
неудовлетворением. То есть один и тот же
продукт, который будет для тела хорошо,
для психики он будет нехорошо. Поэтому
очень важно разобраться тебе с этой
темой, родной. Что ты ешь, что ты
говоришь, на какие темы ты говоришь, что
ты пускаешь сюда, что ты читаешь. Если
ты любишь себя, если ты уважаешь себя,
если ты хочешь жить счастливо, то не
надо в свой сад впускать слона, которые
разрушает его. И ты это делаешь каждый
раз, когда ешь что-то, что убивает твою
психику, расшатывает её.
Когда смотришь что-то, говоришь на
какие-то темы, говоришь какие-то слова,
читаешь что-то, это всё запускание
слона. Запустил слона, он поднял мысль.
Ну я шучу слона, это же состояние
определённое. Это вибрацию запустил. Эта
вибрация поднимает мысли. Ты смотришь на
эти мысли, не можешь себя отличить от
них. Тебе кажется, что ты это сейчас
думаешь, у тебя пошла проблема, всё,
пошла накрутка, ты уже думаешь об этом.
Всё. И фу. Как ты думаешь, к чему это
приведёт? Я до этого уже сказал. Идём
дальше. Следующий момент. Очень,
пожалуйста, внимательно. Его важно
понять. Наша реальность, мы говорили,
она зависит от мыслей. Мысли дают нам
состояние, и в итоге мы действуем, потом
имеем то, что имеем.
Но наше состояние, наша мысль, она
всегда связана с каким-то я, которое это
проживает. То есть есть какая-то
личность, которая это проживает.
И вот в этих отпечатках, в подсознании,
в этих негативных самскарах, да, в
негативных наших прошлых опытах хранится
какие-то я, типа я плохой, я ненужный, я
ничтожный, я я всегда с минусом там.
Другими словами, каждый раз, когда мы
думаем негативно, чувствуем что-то
негативное, включился какой-то
неполноценный я. И для того, чтобы
изменить жизнь, нужно изменить свою
личность, нужно изменить своё я. нужен
полноценный я, который это будет
создавать. Потому что если я не
полноценный, который этого хочет, то я
буду создавать подтверждение своей
неполноценности, переслушая ещё раз эти
слова. Каждый раз, когда я действую из
состояния неполноценности минуса со
знаком минус, я буду создавать действия.
Результат, в итоге, который будет
приходить, он будет подтверждать мне мою
неполноценность. О том, как это сделать,
я скажу в конце, когда дам практические
советы. Седьмой пункт. Представь себе,
ты начал делать то, что ты делаешь. Всё,
у тебя хорошее состояние.
Ты такой: "Всё, моя жизнь изменится, всё
будет теперь ништяк. Да, а тут раз,
что-то бам, какой-то триггер, какая-то
ситуация, какой-то человек и тебя
выводит из себя". И самое интересное,
что ты, ну, я не знаю, какой из
вариантов развития событий будешь
проживать, но обычно это один из трёх,
когда ты начинаешь работать над собой, и
ты понимаешь, что состояние - это самый
важный ключевой фактор. То есть быть в
позитиве, да, быть в благодарности,
чтобы тебе жизнь нравилась, чтобы ты был
полноценным. Но ты встречаешься со
своими близкими,
которые: "А что это ты вот это? А что ты
вот так? Да может быть, ты в сек
какую-то попал? А что ты там делаешь?
Ну или просто какие-то ситуации
происходят, которые включают триггеры,
да, какие-то подсознательные какие-то
отпечатки с твоего прошлого, которые
включают твою неполноценность, да,
задевает тебя за что-то за живое, и тебя
бам, вынесло опять негативное состояние.
А тебе же надо вернуться в позитивное
опять ты опять находишь силы, опять
возвращаешься в позитив, и тебя опять
бабах в негативное какое-то состояние
вынесло. И вот три развития событий,
которые существуют. Первое - это ведро с
крабиками. Когда ты начинаешь меняться,
идти в позитив, ты, ну, это же связано с
конкретными действиями. У тебя питание
меняется, смотрение меняется,
разговорная речь меняется, и ты как
крабик, который хочет выбраться из
ведра. А другие крабы, они такие чик-чик
цепляются и стаскивают назад. Первый
вариант развития событий. Ты пробуешь,
пробуешь, пробуешь, и в какой-то момент
вдруг через годы, [вздыхает]
натыкаясь, допустим, на это видео, ты
осознаёшь, что, оказывается,
ты пробовал несколько лет назад думать
позитивно, быть в хорошем настроении, а
в итоге оказался опять э в ведре с
кровами.
И сейчас это видео служит в очередной
раз напоминанием, что нужно здесь
работать над со своим состоянием, да,
над мыслями. Первое развитие событий -
это человека просто стаскивает, и он
остаётся там, где он был. Может быть,
ещё больше разочарованный, потому что не
получилось, а ему ещё этим имажут.
Видишь, мы тебе говорили, куда ты
лезешь. Второй [вздыхает]
вариант. Ты идёшь дальше, делаешь, у
тебя всё начинает трескаться, отношения
трескаются, семья трескается,
а ты ещё, если, к примеру, не молодой
там парень или девушка, который живёт в
семье там или только переехал, а у тебя
уже семья есть, и может быть такое, что
это доходит до развода, друзья не
понимают и рушится целый мир, родной.
Ну, это не просто. То есть когда ты
говоришь: "Теперь я хочу новую жизнь".
Да, ведро с крабиками не надо забывать.
То есть люди привыкли, близкие привыкли,
что ты себя ведёшь определённым образом.
Ты стал привычным для них, ты стал как
биоробот, а теперь ты становишься
другим. Ты говоришь: "А теперь я это не
хочу". Да как так? Раньше ты бухал, а
теперь ты меня что, не уважаешь? Ну то
есть и многие вот эти вещи, через
которые приходится проходить. И как я
сказал там, может полжизни разрушится,
ну в плане того, что друзья уходят,
семья разрушилась. Может быть такой
вариант, да,
который приведёт к новой жизни. И к
этому надо быть тоже готовым. Готов ли
ты идти на это? Но есть, конечно, третий
вариант. Он,
а-э, не такой негативный, как первые
два. Это когда всё трещит. А трещать
обычно оно будет. Всё трещит, трещит,
трещит, но так как ты идёшь ровно, ты ни
с кем не ругаешься, никому не
доказываешь,
не кричишь, да? А поначалу именно, когда
тебя с ведро с крабиками человек
начинает доказывать, что он ест, почему
он ест, почему теперь он смотрит, не
смотрит, ругаться начинает, и его ещё
больше за дурака начинает читать. Так
вот, если ты никому ничего не
доказываешь, идёшь спокойно, молишься,
может быть, за них, да, не осуждаешь и
не критикуешь никого, то приходит
момент, трескалась, трескалась, потом
раз, всё соединилось и всё наладилось, и
всё. И все те, кто тебя знали, приняли
нового тебя. Но явно всё равно что-то
подпадает, родной. Что-то подпадает.
Может работа измениться, может круг
друзей измениться. Он обычно меняется,
да, к этому надо быть готовым. Ну, дай
бог, чтобы семья сохранялась. Восьмой
момент. Очень важно понимать, наше
физическое состояние тоже влияет на наше
ментальное состояние. Так же, как наше
ментальное состояние влияет на нашу
физику. Я объяснял, да, чик, энергия,
вжик. Также наша физика.
За счёт чего? Ну, к примеру, ты ел, ел,
ел годами какую-то пищу, где-то что-то
пил, с чем-то соприкасался, а там у тебя
куча паразитов, лишний вес и вот это
всё, оно будет влиять на твоё состояние
ума. То есть, если твоё тело наполнено
тяжестью,
оно будет влиять на твой ментал, да? То
есть первое, мысли влияют на твоё тело.
Это то, что мы говорили, твоё тело
выделяет определённые гормоны и влияет
на твои мысли. Ну и наоборот, мы твоё
тело, когда оно нечистое, когда оно не
сильное, когда оно не заряженное,
уставшее, когда ты туда,
да, как как в унитаз что-то смывал в
молодость, оно будет влиять на твои
мыслительные процессы. И в итоге ты
попадаешь как раз вот в этот негатив.
Негативное твоё состояние, уставшее
тело, поднимает негативные мысли.
Негативные мысли будут включать ещё
больше негативного твоего состояния.
Девятый пункт. У нас всегда должен быть
смысл, ради чего мы живём. Виктор Франкл
говорил: "Тот, у кого есть зачем жить,
преодолевает практически любые, как
Виктор Франкл". Он в своё время был в
концлагере и
проживая там это тяжкое время, он
представлял, лёжа на полу, когда было
холодно, когда было голодно, о том, что
он будет, когда закончится война, в
университете давать лекции.
И он тогда выявил, что те люди, которые
жили в концлагере, и у них было ради
чего жить,
был смысл какой-то, они проходили через
эти трудности, а те, у кого смысл
заканчивался, они очень быстро умирали.
Самый главный смысл, который должен
двигать с человеком - это развить любовь
к Богу. То есть любовь к Богу - это
должно стоять на первом месте. Самое
интересное, что это не исключает семью,
это не исключает страну, нацию, религию.
Ну, то есть когда мы что-то одно
выделяем и говорим: "Это должно быть для
меня главным", мы начинаем исключать
другое. А когда мы ставим на первое
место любовь к Богу, то всё остальное
сразу же становится на свои места. Тогда
всё для меня важно. Тогда я смотрю на
этот мир максимально широко. Это же
семья Бога, да? И я забочусь уже тогда
обо всех. И именно вот эта цель должна
двигать человеком. И именно вот эта цель
будет давать ему правильное состояние. И
когда будет трудно, он будет легче
проходить эти все трудности. Читал
недавно слова одного монаха, он говорит
про Иисуса Христа. Бог пришёл и умер как
человек, для того, чтобы человеки, ну,
то есть люди, обрели божественное
сознание. Вдической культуре это
называется сознание Кришны, когда
человек, занимаясь духовной практикой,
вдруг обретает божественное сознание,
которое, по сути, является нашим
естественным сознанием. То есть все мы
божественные души, которые находятся в
этих материальных телах. И развитие
любви к Богу - это наша и естественная
цель, и самое важное, и самое главное. И
всё остальное, как я сказал, оно
становится на свои места. Но цель должна
быть. Десятый момент тоже очень важный.
Когда мы чего-то желаем, мы сомневаемся,
что мы это можем получить.
А точнее, мы можем не верить, что мы это
можем получить. Я говорю, я хочу
зарабатывать много денег. И чем больше у
меня это желание, тем больше у меня
может быть страх или неверие в то, что я
это получу, которое рождает этот страх.
Чем больше у меня желания, тем я могу
больше привязываться к желаемому.
Да, привязанность возникает, вожделение
возникает. Это будет поражать порождать
страх, то есть будет э влиять также на
состояние человека.
Поэтому очень важно, когда возникает
какое-то желание чего-то сделать,
чего-то получить, сказать: "Дорой
Господь, да, я хочу это, да, но всё по
твоей милости, всё по твоей воле. Если
это угодно, то будет это так". Конечно,
нужно действовать, да, прикладывать
действия по отношению к тому, чему ты
хочешь, но именно сама вот эта мысль: "Я
хочу, я хочу, я хочу". Повторять себя,
надо много раз повторять себе это
желание: "Я хочу, я хочу". Ну то есть
если ты много раз в это как бы, ну это
повторяешь, ты не веришь в это, родной.
А по вере вашей дано вам будет. Нужно
уверовать в то, что это произойдёт. По
милости Бога это обязательно будет в
моей жизни, если на то его воля.
Одиннадцатый пункт может быть немножко
быть сложен для понимания,
но я предлагаю тебе поразмышлять на эту
тему. Мы всегда делаем выбор. Даже когда
мы не делаем выбор, мы делаем выбор не
делать выбор. Ну то есть вся наша жизнь,
она устроена из тех выборов, которые мы
сделали. Да и следующие выборы, которые
или решения, которые мы принимаем,
которые приводят нас к действию, они нас
двигают. Просто есть такой момент, что
есть какие-то выборы, которые мы делаем
осознанно, да, я там хочу куда-то пойти,
пошёл, я хочу что-то купить, купил. А
есть как будто мы не можем сделать
какой-то выбор, как будто он делается за
нас. Да, и это бессознательный выбор. Он
делается благодаря, вот то, что я
проговаривал. Есть мысль негативная. В
этой негативной мысли есть я, её
состояние. И в негативном состоянии,
соответственно, по большей части
принимается бессознательный выбор. То
есть выбор делается за нас, и обычно не
туда, куда мы хотим. Поэтому вот это
важно понимать, что вся жизнь - это
череда выборов.
Я делаю этот выбор или за меня делает
программа, да, вот эта штука будет
делать за меня этот выбор. И вот нужно
прийти к тому, чтобы я научился делать
выбор. Даже когда я говорю, к примеру,
там о, я не смог утром встать, хотел, но
не смог. Но это твоё решение было не
смочь встать. Да, лучше сказать, если ты
уже вот лежишь и ты говоришь: "Я сейчас
не хочу вставать". Принять прямо
решение: "Я сейчас не встану". чтобы не
чувствовать чувство вины за то, что у
тебя якобы не получилось стать, потому
что якобы у тебя не было выбора, потому
что ты опоздал. Почему? Потому что якобы
не было выбора. Ну то есть выбор он
всегда есть. Выбор он всегда есть. Вся
наша жизнь настроится вот этих выборов.
Просто есть те, которые бессознательно
принимаются, есть, которые принимаются
сознательно. Нужно вывести жизнь вот
сюда. Если ты живёшь вот здесь, это
разрушает всю твою жизнь, и ты придёшь
не туда, куда ты хочешь. Двенадцатый
пункт. Все варианты реальности уже
существуют. В Багавадгите говорится: "Я
знаю всё, что было, всё, что есть и всё,
что будет". Это значит, независимо от
того, какое действие будет совершено,
встану я, пойду сюда, туда, туда, что бы
я ни сделал. То есть вот это уже
известно Богу. То есть вот эти варианты
событий всех твоей жизни, моей жизни,
они уже есть. Есть ты бедный, есть ты
богатый, есть ты больной, есть ты
здоровый. То есть есть все варианты
тебя. Если ты живёшь бессознательно, то,
что мы говорили до этого, то эти
варианты, ну, ты будешь идти не туда,
куда ты хочешь. За тебя будет принимать
решение, да, бессознательно. То есть
твой ум, опираясь на подсознание, то
есть не подсознание будет на те за тебя
решать, подсознание просто сохранённые
отпечатки. Твой ум, опираясь на
подсознание, на прошлый опыт, будет
создавать мысль, картинку, состояние,
действия, и ты будешь приходить не не
туда, куда ты хочешь. Поэтому очень
важно вот это тоже понимать, что так как
выбор у тебя есть, да, ты можешь выбрать
другую жизнь, но выбрать другую жизнь
должен быть новый я, который эту жизнь
будет проживать. Выйти на сознательный
уровень, уйти от бессознательного,
потому что действовать тебе всё равно
придётся. Это не так, что ты
визуализируешь там желание, говоришь,
там, тебе всё равно придётся
действовать. И это очень важно понимать.
Ответственность она всё равно на тебе.
ясновидящий видит лишь один из вариантов
развития событий, да, когда там
ясновидящае предсказывает, она с
подсознания считывает, один из вариантов
там в твоей жизни будет вот это. Но это
же не факт, потому что, к примеру, когда
я изучал палмистри - это ведическая
культура, скажем, чтение по рукам, и там
говорится, видя линию на руке человека,
которая предвещает беду, нельзя ему
говорить, что у него будет беда. Нужно
сделать все усилия, чтобы направить его
на изменение жизни,
изменение судьбы. Ну то есть сейчас то,
как он живёт, предсказывает беду. А если
его направить по другому пути и он
послушается, то линия изменится. И все
те, кто руки читают, они знают, что
линия на руках меняются. Поэтому мы
также можем изменить свою судьбу, но
меняется она за счёт того, что у нас
меняется состояние, что у нас меняются
мысли, что у нас меняется действие, что
у нас меняется жизнь. А теперь давай
перейдём к практической части.
Пока у тебя нет целостности, пока у тебя
нет вот этого внутреннего
удовлетворения, гармония, пока у тебя
нет вот этого, может быть, а,
а, спонтанного пребывания в себе, когда
ты находишься в своём сердечке и ты
счастлив постоянно, да, удовлетворён и
находишься в благодарности, нужно
периодически себя вытаскивать из
негатива
>> в позитив. Каким способом? Первое, есть
очень хорошее видео у меня на YouTube
канале, оно называется "Режим Бога".
Посмотри его. Это когда ты представляешь
себе то, чего ты хочешь, да?
Прокручиваешь, проживаешь, и как будто
это уже случилось. И когда ты открываешь
глаза, у тебя всегда есть состояние, как
будто вот о так хорошо, всё такое
целостное состояние. И по сути нужно
жить в этом состоянии. То есть увидеть
себя то, кем я стал там, да, какой я, и
жить в этом состоянии. Ну и себя надо
же, соответственно, увидя в этой
картинке, подвести к вот этой версии
себя: какой ты там здоровый, чистый,
красивый, какой-то там. Себя надо
подвести туда. Второе- работа над собой.
И работа над собой, она начинается
всегда с нашего тела. Надо очистить своё
тело. Тут есть паразиты, может быть, да,
у одного или другого, а может быть и у
всех. У нас может быть лишний вес, может
быть много всего того, чего накопилось.
Нужно сделать чисточку,
антипаразитарочку. восстановить
гормональную систему, привести в норму
питания, чтобы питание было хорошо и для
тела, чтобы питание было хорошо и для
психики, чтобы оно удовлетворяло, потому
что, как я сказал, есть питание, которое
хорошо для тела, но оно может, а,
выносить психику. Поэтому нужно всё
привести в гармонию, обязательно
заняться спортиком. Ну, то есть нужно
делать всё для того, чтобы поддерживать
вот эту машину, в которой мы двигаемся.
Да, мы говорили же, что вот это тело,
здоровье вот этого тела, от него будет
зависеть также вот этот ментальный
процесс. Следующий важный пункт - это
режим. Во сколько ты ложишься спать, во
сколько ты встаёшь.
Наша психика зависит от луной энергии. И
поэтому мы должны ложиться до 10:00
вечера. Это уже и научно доказано, и
вставать до 6:00 утра. И тогда ты будешь
себя чувствовать хорошо. Хотя первое
время, если ты будешь привыкать неделю
полторы-две, у тебя будет, наверное,
упадок сил. По крайней мере, у меня так
было. А потом у тебя всегда заряд
энергия. Утром встал, что делать? Ну,
займись, допустим, спортиком 15, 20-30
минут. Йога, да, есть хорошее видео на
Ютубе, э, где я рассказывал про технику
2020, где ты встаёшь, 20 минут,
занимаешься спортом, потом 20 минут
медитируешь и 20 минут читаешь какую-то
духовную литературу или слушаешь лекцию.
Вот это 2020 даст тебе хороший буст.
Прийти, конечно, нужно лучше потом к 606
60, да. Ну, спортом, допустим,
занимаешься там 60 минут, хотя может и
40, и 45, 60 минут хотя бы медитируешь,
но это со временем должно прийти, и
минут 60 хотя бы слушать лекцию, читать
какие-то духовные писания. Это будет
тебя очень сильно развивать,
восстанавливать твою внутреннюю опору,
делает тебя сильным, делает тебя
гармоничным, убирать все негативные
программы. Ну то есть это будет тебя
перепрошивать, родной, потому что ты в
итоге должен прийти к этому целостному
состоянию. Ты должен прийти к этому
внутреннему состоянию, когда у тебя
всегда всё хорошо. И как бы мир не
качало, чтобы где не происходило, дай
бог, чтобы это всегда внутри хорошо
сохранялось. Я рекомендую тебе прочесть
книгу Сердце Льва. Моя книга, она
рассказывает огуны, потому что питание
нужно изменить. Там я рассказал, как это
всё делается. Книга Вкус дикого мёда-
это книга моего духовного учителя.
Обязательно прочесть Баговатгиту, как
она есть. И для тех, кому трудно, на
плохом счету у Бога. Тоже моя книга. В
общем, цель у нас простая. Да, мы
говорим об исполнении желаний, но для
того, чтобы всё исполнялось, нужно
развернуть своё сознание. Оно должно
быть в состоянии благодарности и любви.
И когда ты живёшь в состоянии
благодарности, лю и любви, перед тобой
все двери начинают открываться.
Попробуй проговорить сейчас за мной эти
слова. Слава Богу, что у меня есть Бог.
Слава Богу, что у меня есть ты, мой Бог.
Что ты ощущаешь в моменте?
Внутри сразу становится всё хорошо.
Единственное, что я не сказал в этом
видео я говорил о том, какую личность
нужно создать, про состояние, про мысли,
про тело. Я важные вещи проговорил, но
есть тоже ещё одна очень важная вещь. А
кто настоящий в этом всём? Потому что в
итоге, когда мы говорили о целостности,
о благодарности,
это всё состояние
твоего настоящего я, да? То есть нужно
познать себя настоящего.
Если есть мысли по этому поводу, кто ты,
как себя познать, делись в комментариях,
а также поделись, что ты почувствовал,
когда произнёс вот эти слова. Слава
Богу, что у меня есть Бог. [вздыхает]
Слава Богу, что у меня есть ты, мой Бог.
Дай Бог нам всем божественной любви. M.